okay there it is awesome
yeah thanks Ben for the introduction
first off thank you all for coming to
this first edition of the Meetup I'm
very happy that it's such a great
turnout that bodes well for Vancouver
full-stack and it's it's definitely my
pleasure to present on modern JavaScript
here as as Ben mentioned I'm Jamin
holmgren I am a local I live over in
brush Prairie Washington and and I am a
co-founder of infinite red the so the
topic that I'm gonna be talking about is
modern JavaScript let me talk a little
bit more about my company first infinite
red does react native mainly we also do
react web but a lot of what we do is
react native and then we do some I mean
we have a whole litany of other things
that we do but mainly Ruby on Rails we
do some elixir would use some native
code as well for for applications and
we've been around since 2015 I had my my
business before clear sight for 10 years
2005 to 2015 and then I merged with a
company out of San Francisco called
infinite red and we became the new
infinite red in 2015
and then at that same time we switched
over to react and react native I am the
CTO and we do a lot of open source so I
end up spending a lot of my time on our
open source as well as managing our
engineering team and yeah that's that's
essentially what I also do do our sales
and whatnot there's about 23 to 27 of us
I would say somewhere in that range
depend if you count freelancers that
work with us regularly or not and we
have a design team a front-end team that
does react to react native and a
back-end team and yeah so that's that's
essentially yes we're fully remote
companies so we do have a small office
over in Orchard's but generally it might
be two people there and they're not even
working on the same project so it's I
work from my
from my from my office in my house cool
that so that's about infinite read we
have a slack like everybody else does
community infinite infinite read we talk
a lot of react and a lot of react native
in there there are almost 3,000 people
in there right now and it is a pretty
busy place but it's also not so big that
you just totally get lost like if you go
in there and post you'll generally get
into a conversation with someone there
people are very kind very nice there we
do have speaking of react native we do
have a react native newsletter react
native newsletter calm franklin Hoeven
works for us he's located over in New
Orleans
he is our executive editor and we post
the most relevant react native news
there so if you're interested in mobile
development using react and JavaScript
take a look at this newsletter it's very
good and as Ben mentioned I'm involved
in with the react native Corps team I I
have conversations with the the Facebook
core team as well as I'm one of the
people in charge of one of the modules
that we've pulled out of the the core so
just a really quick thing react native
started as an internal the stock isn't
about reactive but I'm gonna talk a
little bit about it started an internal
thing at Facebook and then they open
sourced it we've been using it in
infinite red and one of the things it
was very tough for them to stay on top
of pull requests and things like that
Facebook so I extracted one of the core
pieces out with their blessing into it's
called react native webview and it
allows you to put web views inside of a
mobile app and then that's one of the
things that I maintain along with
another guy out of France who's great so
yeah so that's the react native
newsletter so this talk is about modern
JavaScript and as I was doing this well
first off let's talk about this quote
here there's nothing so permanent as a
temporary
does anybody know this quote no it was
Milton Friedman okay well that's okay I
will get political here programming hack
is what
so nothing is permanent as a temporary
programming hack and JavaScript
definitely definitely qualifies it was
invented in ten days by Brendan Eich and
it was intended to be essentially a sort
of semi throwaway scripting language for
the web but web developers got ahold of
it and I said wait a min here we can
make things that are not just documents
online we can make things that are
living breathing applications in a
browser right and this was before my
time I started doing web in 2004 so it
was prior to that when JavaScript came
out but when that started happening when
it when it came out Microsoft had their
own version it was called jscript and
you know every browser had their own
implementation and it was just sort of
like a Wild West right so along comes an
organization called ACMA I forget what
it stands for it's actually not super
easy to figure out what it stands for in
a quick google search I found out it
doesn't really matter but they they
named this thing back in the script and
is essentially a it's essentially a
standard write standard for what what
the specification of JavaScript is what
is JavaScript going to be the ECMO as as
we said is you know the standards
Brendan Eich who invented JavaScript
replied to someone last year and said
you know everyone calls a JavaScript
including Microsoft they don't call a
jscript anymore they call it JavaScript
the ACMA script name sounds like a skin
disease and won't ever catch on so he
pretty much put that down don't call it
Eknath script but you do need to know
that it's called ekam script for the
next reason after we get rid of a comma
and call it Java Script in fact we'll
call it modern JavaScript and that's
because you'll hear people talking about
es6 yes seven probably not es eight
maybe but those correspond to the year
they don't correspond of the year that's
probably the version there before that
was yes five there was a yes three etc
but
2015 was es6 2016 is es7 and it goes on
like that most of the time you're gonna
see people refer to it as es 2015 yes
2016 and beyond these are essentially
every year they release a new version
that has you know improvements hopefully
hopefully improvements on the language
itself one of the things to remember is
that not there is no such thing as a
full implementation of es 2015 yes 2016
17 etc you know a browser that has
javascript in it or node which runs it
on a server or wherever you're running
JavaScript there probably aren't just we
are totally 100% compatible with 2016
they'll have slices of it they'll
implement parts of it so no matter what
you do you can't get away from always
looking at particular features which I'm
going to be showing you and making sure
that your your particular targets
support it so what we end up doing is
transpiling you know you could call it
compiling as well but transpilers such
as babel that's the most you know famous
one the one that's probably used the
most as well as typescript itself has
their its compiler will target older
versions of JavaScript
there's Buble and sucrase but basically
these take modern JavaScript and turn it
into a JavaScript that's older so you
know you might have a new feature one of
the features that you're seeing here but
if you're targeting an older browser or
you know any number of browsers
including Internet Explorer then you
need JavaScript that it can run and it's
not going to have all these new features
that I'm about to show you so you would
transpile i'm not gonna show you about
transpilers in this I just wanted you to
be aware of them they're out there most
likely you're gonna see something like
Babel or typescript pipe script doesn't
more than that that will also does more
than that but those are essentially the
most the most famous ones tc39 is
another thing that you're gonna see and
you don't need to memorize these but
you'll probably it'll it'll remind you
of the
hopefully something in this talk tc39 is
the community that is made up of
Microsoft and Apple and Google and
Mozilla and anybody else who is deeply
involved in the browser scene or maybe
node for example note isn't doing a
browser but they're doing a server-side
implementation of JavaScript they all
need to have some input into what
features are being created because for
example let's say that we did something
that you know added something to
JavaScript that worked really great for
node but wouldn't work at all in a
browser context or maybe didn't work on
a phone that would be a problem so they
need to have voices they also bring in a
few invited experts people that have
dedicated a lot of time to doing
JavaScript one example would probably
probably be Brendan Eich you know he'll
he'll probably weigh it it's all open
and you you do have some input into the
process if you want if you want to be
involved so my talk is going to be about
the new features since legacy JavaScript
I'm going to for the purposes of this
talk consider anything es5 and earlier
to be a legacy yes five was around for a
very long time and it's more or less
what you would know basically what I
started with you know using JavaScript
way back when and it took a very long
time to get to es6 or yes 2015 but I'm
gonna go through what what what's new in
JavaScript since that time so there's a
little bit of an assumption that you
might know JavaScript up to that point
may not be true
but I'll try to make it interesting
regardless as I started making the
slides for this I realized how big of a
topic that is so I narrowed it down to
the parts of JavaScript that are new
that I'm interested in so that's what
you're gonna hear I'm gonna mention some
other ones so there's some other pieces
that are that are interesting but this
isn't your what you're witnessing is
JavaScript going from that that ugly
hack that you know originally was
intended to just be a throwaway language
into something that is honestly becoming
wildly the most popular certainly the
fastest
language out there and being used for
all kinds of things including building
native mobile apps strangely so many of
them so let's just launch into this and
I'm gonna go ahead and and as I go
through this there will a lot of times
be examples of the old as well as the
new way of doing things and I'm gonna
explain a little bit more about that so
variables previously and yes well really
since the beginning you would define a
new variable with var you'd say var foo
equals five or something like that
var well it has been replaced you don't
use a bar anymore at all you can still
use bar they don't break anything ever
in JavaScript they they try not to
anytime that they are changing something
it has to have pretty much a not zero
impact on web sites that are in the wild
so you've got some new variable scopes
and bindings there's let and there's
Const so essentially there was a problem
with a bar number one is you could take
var and then you could assign it you
know assign a value to a variable and
then it I'll show you an example in a
bit the scope could actually leak
outside of where you might want it to be
used
additionally there wasn't really a way
to make sure that that variable never
got rebound to a new value now it's a
little different than what you might
think of as an immutable or like frozen
value that that's a different concept
but rebinding is what cost is for so
make let's not var I don't know
[Laughter]
[Music]
one of my guys came over there so so
don't use a bar anymore use let or Const
so let works almost the same as var
where you could literally go through
your older codebase and replace every
instance of var with let with one
problem though it is limited to the
block scope it's not a problem it's a
it's a feature but it will break things
in certain cases if you're not careful
so here's an example if true and then we
have we open up a block right and we
create a new variable of our name equals
George and then we console.log it and of
course we get George that's what we
expect then we get out of that if and we
console.log the name and we get George
that means that this name lives on even
past the scope that it was defined in
okay doesn't seem like a big deal until
you start working with really big
applications and you don't know what's
gonna be further up the page you know
possibly and that can be a problem
so with let we do the exact same thing
let name equals George console name same
thing but if you try to console.log
outside of it it will say that the name
is not defined so as you can see that is
the difference and this is why they
couldn't just change the semantics of
var they couldn't just say well now var
is going to do this now because you're
gonna break applications that are
relying on this behavior and that's one
thing they can't do they have millions
literally millions of websites out there
that are probably doing this exact thing
or something like it and you don't want
to be breaking those semantics so you
have to come up with new names in this
case lead cost works exactly the same
way except for you can't rebind it you
can't go and say now name is something
else it will it will fail infinite read
we use pretty much use Const unless we
need to be able to rebind it some people
have different opinions on that and
think that you should use let and
because it's shorter and and that's fine
like use whatever works for you there
are also some new
operators so what is an operator it's
like the plus sign it's it's you know
like symbols that do things allow you to
build and like manipulate data and
whatever one of my favorites is the
spread operator so this is three dots
periods and you'll see this in other
languages as well it's one of those
things that once you've started using it
you don't really want to go back to not
having not having it in your toolbox so
let's say that we create two objects
we've got basic info and it consists of
a first name and a last name and our
employment information which is company
and and job and these are just
containing strings but they could
contain whatever and you want to combine
those two things into a new object so
what you would do with es2015 prior to
es2015 you'd have to do like a loop and
actually go through all the properties
and construct an object but in es2015
there's a new function or a new method
on object called a sign and you'd simply
you would create a new empty object
because whatever is the first object
there gets mutated with all the
information it grabs everything from
basic info dumps it in there everything
from employment and dumps it in there
and then you can just keep going so I
created another one right here and I
forgot a parenthesis right there but you
get food and tacos and and everything
oops so the with the spread operator we
don't have to do this what we can do is
we can spread it we can dot dot and then
the variable and that brings in all of
the the properties from that object into
the new object that we're creating and
this is exactly the same thing but it
just looked a little prettier and this
would probably be sugar to this in the
background if you were targeting
something that was es2015 so that's a
new feature in JavaScript that you
couldn't do before and it would take a
lot more lines of code to you know to
achieve the same effect and then this is
the result of both of these and you get
all
the different properties spread out
among their it's always last in wins too
so it'll overwrite anything that was
previously in there yeah conversely to
the spread operator we have these
structuring so we were creating an
object a new object before these
structuring is really cool because now
you can pull pull information out of an
object so let's say that we have an
object it's a person notice we're using
cost here it's you could use let you
could use bar but we're not going to and
we're creating a new object and it has
name hair and height and we want some of
that information out of that object we
want to pull that out for a particular
purpose right so previously what you'd
do is you'd have var name equals person
name and var hair equals person dot hair
and then you could log it out and you
know or do whatever you wanted with it
right so not too bad but you know lines
of code you'd have to add more lines of
code to to achieve the same thing with
destructuring you do the cost but then
you open up a new sort of block like
syntax here and give it the names of the
properties and those get bound to the
values actually get bound right there
equals person so it does the exact same
thing up here in fact it probably
compiles down to that if you use a
transpiler
I'll be doing that exact same thing so
but now we have a variable named name
and a variable named pair that come out
of the person it's very cool and you get
the same result right here notice that
we're not touching height and either of
these but we could if we wanted to so
it's only pulling in there for the
information out that we want there's
also the object rest the dot rest so
this is the opposite of spread what
we're doing here is we have the this is
what we would do before we would
probably duplicate the person object
either using object assign or some other
method and then we would delete from the
new
let me back up a second what we want to
do is we want to take this this person
we want to remove their their name but
leave the hair in the height we want to
keep the hair in the height in a new
object and then we also want to have the
name so we're just deleting the name out
of the new object that we had and we're
also grabbing it there so we have our
name we have the new object with the
hair and the height with these with the
rest operator we do the same thing as
destructuring but we just do rest and
it'll just grab anything else that we
did not specify and put it into a brand
new object that now goes into that's
called rest so you can see that it's a
it's a cleaner nicer implementation and
it's helpful in certain cases if you
just want to throw away a value you
could do that or if you need that value
you can do that as well
any questions so far I'm going kind of
fast here and yes that's right it is not
you can name this j-man if you wanted or
whatever it just becomes a variable that
becomes it's that new object it's this
right here so you can you can yeah name
it anything you want yep exactly
yep and not only that but you can put
other ones here so you have name but you
could also put you know height comma
rest and then that dot rest would only
have the hair left in it that's the only
thing that it would have if you
completed everything if you took
everything out then it would just be an
empty object okay and by the way these
are very very helpful all of these are
very very helpful if you're trying not
to mutate you notice that in this one
we're mutating this we're deleting a
property off of a existing object which
can have it can have you know
consequences in your code if you pass
something into a function and you're not
expecting your copy of it to be mutated
and changed so these things all really
help the spread operator as well as
rest and destruction yes yes yes oh wait
so no okay so if I only put hair there
it would leave name in there so anything
you don't specify will stay in there
yeah because they're not really it's not
really think of it as an ordered thing
it's just kind of plucking the pieces
out that it means and if all you did was
dah dah dah rest nothing else it would
be a copy of person it wouldn't be the
exact same object it'd be a brand-new
object but it would be exactly exactly
the same otherwise so that is a way to
copy if you want to good question
any other questions yes yes yes if you
use the triple equal yeah
it'll say false yeah correct and if you
wanted to check whether they were equal
or not in that yeah you know practically
equal not perfectly equal then you'd
have to use some sort of like DP equals
or something like that to compare the
values yep mm-hmm
good questions all right um let's see
here there's so one of the things this
one's not a big deal like it's not my
favorite you know new feature that they
added but they're doing they're also
doing some things to just sort of make
your life a little bit easier you know
JavaScript Rossum was missing an
exponent operator there was no real way
to eat not with not with an operator you
couldn't do an exponent mathematical
operation we had to do is call a method
on the math object except itself pow
now I I'm not I'm not someone who uses
that that method all that often right
it's not it's not something that I do
every day but it's an example where they
just add too
two asterisks becomes the exponent
operator and so what one of the things
that they're doing is just sort of
bringing JavaScript up to up to speed
with a lot of other modern languages
other modern languages have an operator
for this so why not JavaScript same
exact syntax yeah so there you you're
gonna if you know other languages you're
gonna notice that they're stealing a lot
of stuff from those other languages
exactly they're kind of exactly because
for a very long time their JavaScript
sort of been a joke and we all joke
about it right even though even those of
us who use it every day
there's there's something about
JavaScript where it's just kind of it's
yeah it's it's like oh you know
JavaScript there's there's a great video
by Gary Bernhardt I think it's called
watt w80
and look it up it's funny and he kind of
goes through a lot of this sort of
head-scratching things with javascript
he is using an older version of
JavaScript where there were more of
those a lot of those have been addressed
I do have a watt in here at some point
template string literals this is one of
my absolute favorites I use it anywhere
I possibly can
I really love this I love this there's
an even cooler one next well maybe I so
named Jamin holmgren and this is a
pretty standard one I was even with
Callie here I was showing her how to do
this sort of thing with console.log she
wanted to know what programming was like
and I showed her basically like
something like this right so you have a
string that you're assigning the name
and then you have console dot log hi my
name is plus name plus and then you the
rest of your string and a lot of times
it's just punctuation or something right
very very yes we've all been written
this line of code I'm sure this is a
template string literal string template
literal use backtick for reasons I'll go
into in a second
hi my name is dollar sign curly and then
whatever you want in there as long as
it's valid JavaScript so it reads nicer
you don't have these kind of operators
kind of interrupting your your
here so why didn't they just change the
semantics of single quote or double
quote to allow for this dollar sign
curly I mean why not it seems pretty
pretty obvious that you could just do
that well there were a nonzero number of
strings out there somewhere that we're
using this and not expecting it to be
evaluated as JavaScript you know maybe
they were showing something in another
language that uses the same same
interpolation to you know to like
display something on the on maybe it was
help or something for a different
language they didn't want that then to
break and be like this is not valid
JavaScript so there's a long discussion
about it and the end result was we need
to use a different a different character
and they came up with backtick when I
first saw that it was very jarring and I
kind of like you know that medicine that
doesn't look right but I've gotten so
used to it now no big deal I'll even put
back tics when I don't need to put back
tics because it's whatever it's fine so
a note about the name in here you can
literally write another JavaScript
program inside that those Curly's like
there's nothing stopping you it's an
expression so whatever the last you know
value is will eventually get rendered
into this string but you could just put
in you know a variable which a lot of
people that's what they use it for but
you could also call out to a function or
you could whatever anything that returns
something that can be interpreted back
into a string any questions about the
the template string literals these are
very very helpful and as always if you
were to transpile this it would turn
pretty much back into this so another
cool thing about template string
literals is this we used to have to do
this or we still have to do this if
you're using a double quote if you want
to do a multi-line string for whatever
reason if you didn't if you if you just
did a newline
javascript is just throws up its hands
like I I don't know what you're trying
to do here there's a single quote and
then a new line a lot of other languages
don't have a problem with this but
JavaScript did so yes there's a joke
knock knock who's there very long pause
Java we got a we got to make fun of Java
in this and you'll notice that we have
back slashes at the end of each line as
well as back slashes around the quotes
because of course that's the that's the
delimiter of the string and we can't be
you know prematurely
yeah stopping our stream there so this
isn't great and I've actually written
lines of code like this and it's not
it's not great even if is there yeah see
that's how that's how bad this is
yeah it screws you up doesn't it you had
me going totally yeah yeah it would yeah
so probably so it's it's actually
escaping the new line and you know
having forbid if you put a space there
or something right if you put a space
there it's gonna you got a problem so
with a template string they change the
semantics so that new lines are no
longer need to be escaped they just work
as you would expect obviously without
starting and ending it with a double
quote now you don't have to escape that
anymore I didn't have to escape the
single quote either which I didn't have
to hear but if I had put a single quote
before and after I would have had to on
this side and we also get the benefit of
interpolation don't know I could have
put it right after here this is
beyond the scope of my talk yes I so no
I I just did that I could have totally
put it there if I wanted to this adds an
additional new line to my string school
so those are very cool tagged template
strings this is pretty new even if
you've been using modern JavaScript you
may not be aware of this okay
so I kind of wish I'd done this this
slide backwards this is my first time
giving this talk your beta testers so
but I'll start with the implementation
and then I'll show you what the API
looks like actually no I'm not I'm just
gonna skip through to the API okay so
look at this line right here console.log
bold if I then back tick hi my name is
dollar sign name okay so it looks like a
normal template literal but this bold if
I tells it go find a function that is
called bull defy and pass in the parts
that of the string and it breaks it
apart into hi my name is and then
exclamation point and also pass in the
inserted parts which would be in this
case name as additional parameters after
that no I'm I'm doing a rest here again
going back to the whole rest thing I can
name it whatever I want I could have
named this rest this is in a function
definition we haven't talked about that
error functions yet but we'll get there
and then what I can do is I can map
through all of the different parts so I
would grab hi my name is and the
exclamation point and in between and any
inserted part I output the strong the
the string a strong tag the inserted
part and the other strong tag and the
result becomes hi my name is strong game
and Holmgren n strong so I can basically
annotate the different parts it gives me
all this information all these different
parts and I can do cool things with them
you could maybe build some sort of like
HTML rendering thing where you needed to
add additional you know divs or whatever
to each part as you as you insert it so
it's a very cool thing tag template
strings I think it probably comes into
play a little bit more if you're
building libraries like hey here's how
to use my library use bold Fi and it'll
just work but this is a complete
implementation I've tested it works yeah
so that's another thing that's kind of
coming down the pike there are actually
quite a few of these new features that
are really more aimed at library authors
than application developers because
basically it gives them the tools that
they need to build dsls or whatever that
give you a more pleasant experience when
you're using their library this is this
might be yes 2018 I actually don't know
it's that is the SX no kidding okay so
it's it is a yes 2015 been around a lot
longer than I expected I actually didn't
know about this until probably last year
sometime and then I never did actually
use it in an application alright so
let's talk about what the changes that
have come to functions the most obvious
one is arrow functions sort of fat arrow
functions or whatever you might want to
call them this is the smallest function
you can create in JavaScript it's just
two parentheses well you can probably
make a slightly smaller one but a fat
arrow equal greater than and then two
Curly's so the old way let's let's look
at this piece of code and then see how
the fat arrow function helps helps us in
this situation this hat this happens a
lot when you're doing things like
building react components and whatnot so
we actually end up with an error here so
there's an actual problem with this code
we're creating an object we're giving it
a couple of properties which are name
and languages okay the different
languages here and then we have another
property that has a function which is
say and then what we do is we loop
through this dot legs dot for each we
pass into the for each method a function
that takes whatever language it is as L
binds it to L and we console eight lug
this time iam coming back to this you
know containing object likes whatever
language was passed it so it looks like
it should work right it does not
when you say objects a it says cannot
read property name of undefined now if
you're working with this in JavaScript
get very comfortable with this line of
code or line of error message here
cannot read property whatever of
undefined just means that somewhere this
lost its scope and it's not what you
expect so so that was a problem because
when when we would have this function
here it would unset this basically and
it was no longer bound to this original
object notice that this thought Lang's
worked so in the original function it
worked fine it was the next function
where it lost its scope so we needed a
way to say I want to keep the outer
scope with this this needs to stay the
same don't mess with this so along come
arrow functions in addition to being
slightly more pleasing in my opinion
maybe not in everybody's opinion but
slightly more pleasing to read it also
ensures that this dot name can stays
bound to the name okay
now there was a way by the way to bind
that function to the outer this you
could say at the end of the function dot
bind that parentheses this there was a
way to kind of do that but it was just
kind of awkward
felt weird now this works Damon likes
jsj me likes Ruby Jamin likes elixir and
I ran that code so I know it works
notice that the save function I did not
do the fat arrow function that's because
I didn't want it to inherit the outer
this outside of the object I didn't want
it to you know I wanted
to get the new context so you're not
going to totally get away from writing
function unless unless you know unless
you know what you're doing there may be
some ways but you're probably not going
to get away from writing function there
are places for both and that's fine
there's no problem with adding features
and then using the new features for what
they're intended for and the older
features for they're intended for what
they're good for
so if you were to do this it would then
say this thought Lang's is undefined
because it's it's now looking outside of
the object all right any questions about
the arrow functions and the scope that's
happening here I realize that this is a
fairly there's a lot there's a lot going
on here this right here it's actually an
L I should have written it out but I was
starting to get to the edge here so I
just kept it short it meet it stands for
the language yes that would be fantastic
that so that that's how you would have
done it that's true you could have I
maybe that'll be in version two of my
talk but just to recap yes exactly
just to recap you're gonna post a link
explaining this in more detail than
anybody wanted to know probably perfect
please do that and then he was saying
that you could assign a variable self
equals this or something like that and
then use that internally in the next
function to solve the problem here which
is that's what we used to do and yeah
Zack and Wendell perfect awesome thank
you so you'll see where you see the the
arrow functions come in a lot if you're
doing to react because that's the one
I'm the most familiar with it's when
you're doing things like passing an
event handler so like on click run this
function if you pass in an arrow
function the this that gets handed over
to the error handler that eventually
calls it will retain my this and not
lose it along the way that's a very
common newbie mistake is to pass in a
function to an air handler that loses
its reference and can't call back to it
doesn't it doesn't know where it's from
yes right
sneak peek into my next slides yes
exactly
what Ryan was mentioning was that you
there there are some other aesthetic
sort of improvements that arrow
functions bringing and I'm gonna go
through those actually in the second
year so another is explicit versus
implicit return so in Ruby I did a lot
of Ruby and elixir too I think whatever
is the last expression will get returned
from the function so if you don't want
to return anything you would have to
like put a meal there or something right
in JavaScript unless you return it will
always be on defiant okay so right here
we have function name it returns the
name this function doesn't do very much
but you can see you have to write return
and you also need to have curly braces
before and after it this is just part of
the function keyword the new way to
write this is you can you can go ahead
and just simply move it over and it
looks exactly the same it still has the
the arrow function it has the arrow here
instead of the function but it still has
the Curly's and it still has the return
so you could just do that and that's
fine
right as long as you're aware of the
this changes that that will happen that
that will bring along with it there you
can only do explicit or you can do
explicit with both the old syntax and
the new syntax you can only do implicit
with the new syntax you remove the the
curly braces and then whatever
expression whatever the end of that
expression is whatever the whatever it's
it returns will get returned from get
name so and by the way you can also drop
down a line if you want if you didn't
want to do a two line I tend to avoid
these if I have to drop down one then
I'll put Curly's and do an explicit
return it's just I've been bit by this
sort of thing before you do not need the
braces if you're doing an implicit
return so this and this are functionally
exactly the same they do exactly the
same thing this takes a name and returns
a name
this takes a name and returns the name
it's just more wordy about it so I'm
gonna show you another example as well
maybe not actually so Ryan was talking
about the parameter so we have this name
parentheses arrow and then the body of
the function in this case we're
returning whatever console.log returns
which spoiler alert it's undefined
it doesn't actually return anything but
we're logging it out and returning
undefined and we're taking that name as
the one parameter we only have one
parameter which is really common it's
really common to have functions that
only have one parameter and just happens
all the time so you can just get rid of
them the parentheses the the parser can
understand this and knows of this is
still a function still assigns this
function to same name and you still get
the name and you can still console.log
them it still returns undefined so that
make sense cool if you have two or more
parameters then you do need your
parentheses and that is because comma is
a an actual operator in JavaScript you
can write like one expression comma
another expression and you generally
don't but you can it's part of the
language and so if you were to do a
comma B arrow it doesn't know if you're
just trying to say a and then B arrow or
a b arrow like it doesn't it's a it's
like a operations thing so you do need
two parenthesis if you're running into
this sort of a situation okay
between no no it's just it's just for
visual kind of reducing clutter because
these tend to not just be like this is a
pretty clean example you're not gonna
see it's obvious what's happening but if
you're in the middle of like other
parentheses happening you know you're
passing into for each or something and
you're then you have extra parentheses
or like an on click or something like
that you've got all these symbols
happening around it and it's just the
visual noise kind of gets to you so by
removing them in the majority case where
it's only one set one parameter it
reduces the visual noise that's the idea
anyway
another advantage to modern JavaScript
is a trailing comma before if you did
this it would be an error so we are
defining an add to function and saying
you know parameter ABCD and I couldn't
in the past I couldn't put a comma after
the last one and the question is why
would you want
I actually was that right I actually
didn't know that okay that's interesting
well it made it into the spec yes it
made it into the spec so why would you
want to do that well a lot of times
you're like copying and pasting whole
lines like this and when you do that you
don't want to have to like oh I need to
reorder these or something now the next
one above it has doesn't have a comma so
by doing this you just kind of keep the
commas all in one place and it works
I think Jason five might have it
actually but you have to have a specific
parsers yeah I think that the latest
version does have that exactly they also
allow comments so that's cool yeah if
you use them like a relatively recent
JSON parser then you can do stuff like
that but yeah let's talk about async
await so yes
five or es2015 yes six or yes 2015
introduced promises and promises were
ways to write asynchronous code code
there were promise implementations prior
like I think jQuery had their own
implementation there are a few others
but they standardized it into one one
you know standard implementation so this
is how you would write it and it was
nice because we didn't have this
capability before or it would be
convoluted so there's a little bit going
on here I'll just kind of go through it
we have a function get post count you
know we're calling out to like the
backend API to figure out what is the
the post count and what we're returning
is a promise with a function that we get
a resolved function it gets passed into
us from promise itself promise will
actually give us a resolved function
then we go out to our API object let's
just pretend like we have an API object
with a get user method on it pass in the
user ID that we got through the post
count and then with a dot then that's a
promise because it's dot then I mean I
think if I hit space yes we have a dot
then we will get the user and then we
need to go out with the user and we need
to get the posts this is not a very well
you know designed API tends to be the
case sometimes and we're also doing
another then and we're passing in
another function and we're getting the
post there and then we call back to that
original resolved function that we got
and give the post dot length and then we
get it and this is how we use it get
post count passing the for like user ID
for and then we get the count and then
we can do something with it this is one
of the more like simple examples and you
can see if you have many things going on
how this could easily start kind of you
see this shape right here like that it
keeps going and going and going and you
just kind of get this tree tree tree -
tree - all the way down your file if you
have like a
or or vs code or something that little
mini version of your code on the right
side where you call that the map and you
can just see it doing that all the way
down so in order to make this a more
pleasing and maybe a little more
straightforward way to do asynchronous
code they introduced async away and this
was a blatant ripoff of other languages
so this does I believe exactly the same
thing user ID cost user remember we got
that user in the function callback
before let me actually back up
we got user right there right then
user now we're just saying cost user
equals so it just waits for it to finish
and then puts it into user then we wait
for posts we pass in the user and we get
that back and then we return the post
that length this reads like imperative
code just straight all the way down
right even though when it wait happens
it's going off and doing other stuff and
then it comes back and resumes once it
gets the information that it means and
then to use it notice I'm not using a
weight here I can if I'm in another
asynchronous function but on the top
level I have to go back to the dot then
syntax because top-level JavaScript does
not support async await they are working
on that and so that could eventually be
count Const count equals a weight get
post count for correct I'll show you an
example of that in a bit yes so so this
essentially cleans up your your code now
there are some cases and you'll actually
see that in the try catch where you may
look at it and say I don't think that's
better and that's okay because you can
still use the old the old way if you
want so just you know be aware that both
tools are in your toolbox I do need an
async keyword
if you just do a regular function it
won't work it'll say I don't know how to
do this because what it's doing behind
the scenes is rewriting it to the
previous thing that you saw its
rewriting it all into a bunch of you
know like that again right and then we
have V awaits so those are the new
async/await
now there is a in promise there's also
like a promise dot all
you can await promise that all so I have
fetch a fetch B and fetch C and I push
them all into an array and I'm at I
don't want to wait for each one to
finish I want to say fetch a waiting
waiting waiting okay now that's done
fetch be waiting waiting waiting I don't
want to do that I could I could do that
I could say wait wait wait I just don't
want to do that because it's gonna take
too long and really B and C don't don't
depend on a I can just fire them all off
and wait whenever they come back they
come back so using promised at all I can
await that all three of those get
awaited at the same time when they're
all done you get an array back with a B
and C and those are the results now if
you do that and Ryan will attest you
just ran into this if you do that with
20 API requests or something you might
get rate limited or actually in Ryan's
case wasn't it you blew up your memory
yeah yeah yeah so so do be careful with
promised at all there's a really cool
library out there by Dan levy called F
promises that promises I think it's
called and it it allows you to do things
like how many concurrent at a time and
it'll it'll wait and and like to only
batch them and I'm at yes yeah
the promises yeah yeah there are
problems with that as well it's it's
kind of a it's kind of a brute-force
tool it works in the majority of cases
but if you need more fine-grained
control they're gonna want to use
something else like that F promises
library or something else
another one is rxjs and some others that
they kind of have a lot a lot more
control over the what what you know
asynchronous code like that so here's an
interesting one it's for weight of and
this is a pretty brand new one that i
actually used myself but who can spot
the problem with this here we have an
async function and we are awaiting on
each promise can you tell what's gonna
happen here you kind of want it to run
serially because you want to wait before
the next one fires off we're trying to
wait on it we don't want to fire them
all off at once problem is that each
function will pause but you're gonna
have 30 functions that are all paused
waiting but they're all gonna fire off
at once so it's not actually waiting
before it goes to the next loop okay and
this is a this is a problem with async
await it may not be super obvious but if
you do the old-school for like the the
for counter like iterator method I mean
a statement then you can do this and
it'll work properly but that feels like
a step backwards it's like we have for
each why are we doing four and like
counting through and you know using that
so they they came up with four await
which basically does what we wanted it
to do it awaits each object out of it
waits each promise assigns it to object
and you can do stuff with object once
it's resolved and it waits each time so
these are
yes exactly of you'll see that and I
don't actually go into that much but you
can you can do more research on the the
four of its a much better version of of
the for statement cool another sort of
quality of life thing I've done this
before where I check to see if ooh is
even defined if it's not then I give it
a default value otherwise I use foo okay
and again is bar undefined then I'll use
a default value of seven and then other
way if it is if they gave me something
that all you know then I'll use it and
then you can continue on and do your
thing with the new syntax you can
actually say foo equals five bar equals
seven and it does exact same thing is
here you've seen this in other languages
too Ruby has this you can just say
equals something JavaScript didn't have
this and so they they allowed this one
cool thing is that you can use previous
parameters as default values
so who equals fifty bar equals foo minus
ten
that's kind of cool so if I were to pass
in my funk 25 then it would actually
console.log bar as 15 there because it's
taking taking 25 minus 10 so it actually
allows you to do a full like JavaScript
expression there I don't know if you can
do that I think you can actually I
haven't tried it put a function in there
yes so so that's kind of cool I I very
rarely seen it used but you can do that
let's talk about classes so I tend to
not be a huge class fan but at the same
time they are a new feature of
JavaScript and it's it's a pretty
significant one and it's used all over I
tend to be I guess because my Alixe
background I tend to like you know bare
objects and functions
so your basic classes we have a class
rectangle give it a constructor you can
pass in a height and a whip and then it
assigns that to instance properties and
then so if I were to create an erect new
rectangle 150 seventy five we've got I
actually did that backwards but yes
width and height there all right you get
the idea if you've done other languages
that have classical inheritance this
looks very similar now there are some
differences underneath the hood because
it's still using its prototypical
inheritance and everything but I'm not
gonna go into that in this talk okay
here's a little more a little more to
this example in this case we're actually
defining default values for these
properties height and width it's very
very clean and like you know just kind
of what you would expect right a
constructor does the same thing in this
case we actually define in a getter so
if you try to access the dot area it
actually runs a function instead and
returns that so you can set do getters
you can do setters it's just set
whatever and then that takes the value
that you're setting it to and you can
you can save it somewhere else or or
send it off somewhere in this case we're
actually calling out calc area which
takes this dot io x to start with and
returns it so classes do have some kind
of cool things you can oh yes yeah I
think you can yeah yeah I believe you
can and then those those get bound
though to actually I don't know do those
get mound to the the the instance
properties I'm actually not sure if they
get bound to the instance properties or
if they're just local variables that you
then use but I think there's actually a
way to do the instance properties beyond
instance you can also do just static
things so static means like on the class
the main like
class so app static app name and Static
name so I can just say app name I'm not
doing like a new app instance and then
calling methods on it I'm just calling a
cop dot name here static means that
before what you have to do is like
create an object called app and then do
app dot name equals something this is
just more more MORE what you would
expect from a class and I am using as
you can see there this and interpolation
there's a new one coming which is this
kind of pound sign hash tag whatever it
is for a private property so if you
don't want that accessible outside of
the class like you know you create a new
instance and then you don't want someone
doing the instance dot app name then you
put that little hash they're still
accessible but but only two methods for
that class so these are just things that
you know Ruby has had since 1995 or
whatever this is this is just stuff
where Java scripts catching up again
inheritance I'm not gonna go into this a
lot but you can extend other classes you
do have to call super because you need
to call the original constructor you're
overriding its constructor so you need
to call it yes it is still true yes that
is essentially that is essentially what
it's for I mean it's a you know classes
are a valid way to write programs it's
not like you know and they do i what i
found is yeah exactly
I found that objects make the most sense
when you're making games and things that
are very like object oriented there's an
object
down the screen so when I'm making games
I actually use classes because it
actually kind of makes sense to me it
works you know but when I'm writing web
applications I'm I'm not doing that
maybe if this was Vancouver game stack
we would be doing more of that cool all
right I'm going over time here so I'm
gonna roll right along there is all
there's a lot more to classes than that
I'm just giving you a taste of it nice
um there's some new methods so Ray dot
prototype dot includes any time you see
prototype that just means that when you
create a new one it's gonna add all
these these methods on to your new
instance your brand Lee Brandt brand new
instance so let's say that you had
States Washington Oregon and California
and you wanted to see if in States you
had Washington then you run your reign
constantly function that is really
helpful I use that includes all the time
it is it's it's great what you used to
use is index of and does anybody know
the gotcha with index of returns an
integer of the position and negative one
negative one if it's not there so you
can't say if like states dot index of
Washington because if it's at the first
position will return 0 which evaluates
to false and if it's not there it'll
return negative one which evaluates to
true exactly yes so yes now obviously
dot includes is probably just index of
not equal negative one right like under
the hood it's probably doing something
like that it's not quiet I wouldn't
actually looked at the implementation
there's a little more to it but yes
object values this is a weird one I have
no idea why they didn't have this like
way back in the s5 because they had yes
they had keys back in es5
object keys why couldn't they do values
that didn't make sense at all to me but
they finally got it in in like 2018 or
17 so what you would do before is you
would do object keys of you know let's
say that I have this scoreboard right
these are my my business partners and of
course I'm way ahead of everybody except
for Hannah
I hope they watch this I and but I want
to actually like out put a scoreboard I
want to say name and then score and I
need the the values so object keys score
mapping the key and then I grab back in
this original score and refer to that
index you know it might be Jamin and
then it comes out as 42 so that's
literally the whole implementation in my
opinion of object values now you can do
object I values cool I don't know why it
took them so long there's probably some
story like someone was arguing about
something and who knows what I do use
that there's also object on entries this
would actually be more helpful if you're
doing the scoreboard because it gives
you both right here right so then you
could you know console.log and actually
I think I put an example yes I did
so object out entries score for each and
I'm destructuring
an array here so the first element is
name and I didn't I could have put
anything there I could put foo or
whatever it would always grab the first
element when you're doing square bracket
and then your d structuring the second
element score you're gonna see this more
often if you're a react developer now
with a new thing called hooks because
they return an array in the first
element is the value in the second
element is a setter function or
something like that so you're gonna see
this destructuring array positionally
not by name more often but i get the
name right here and i get the score
right there and i look through them and
i console.log name has score okay so
that's what object entries is good for
any questions about values or entries or
any of those methods
right there are always ways to do it so
you could you know use lodash or jQuery
in some cases or Ram des but because
they weren't hard to write but you know
having third-party libraries provide
your standard library isn't ideal
or prior to that prototype where to
actually extend the original objects
which was a real problem later when they
decided to make you know real methods
string dot prototype pad start pad end
so how does anybody remember a little
incident called left pad yes there's an
NPM module is probably like three lines
of code or something that millions of
applications were using whether they
knew it or not because it was probably
some dependency of a dependency of a
dependency where it would pad this
starts in the ends of strings so and
then what happened was the author of the
NPM module had an existential crisis or
something and he just yanked it off of
there he published the whole thing
deleted everything off of you know it
was gone and it broke everybody's builds
yeah it was a long time and so obviously
it was easy to rewrite but it had forced
some changes with NPM where you can't do
that anymore you can't go and like break
you can deprecated but you can't delete
things that have been out there for a
while and also they created their own
like standard library versions of these
oops I there is one thing warning with
emojis emojis use utf-8 they use like
two characters to you know do like a
flush space or whatever so it can
actually you can have unexpected results
with this I don't have a solution to
that problem I'm just giving you the
problem
promised the prototype that finally so
this is our our try/catch so you can
with promises do a Venn and a catch so
if you get an error back then you can
handle the air they added finally now so
you can also run after either a
successful or an unsuccessful promise
finally will always run and that gives
you you know like I don't care if I had
an error or I got a success either way
turn off the spinner all right we're
done this is the async await version so
we have a wait and then we're we're
trunk doing a try around our weight and
this is how you catch errors
it looks more like regular imperative
code oh wait handle response my requests
if if that works then it'll go to the
next line and you can start using the
JSON there otherwise catch the error and
handle it and then after either of those
set is loading to false with finally
okay so both of those basically do the
same thing and this is a situation where
I would look at this one and say that's
actually kind of it's almost nicer but
that's up to you here's my watt so what
is what return here try return true
finally return false what would you
expect to happen true yeah
it's false so no matter what happens in
try even a return it will always run
finally it overrides it and if that
returns false that's what you get back I
don't know I don't really see like an
obvious solution to that because finally
supposed to run right and you don't want
it to not run
I don't know if I understood what you
said there oh okay so there is a real
reason for that yes yes only when it
returns does it override yeah so there's
a bunch of stuff I didn't talk about
symbols which are used more internally
and things but you can use them if
you're doing something fancy generator
functions which kind of I don't know if
they predated I think they predated
async/await and maybe like async/await
is sort of like sugar on top of
generator functions we we used to use
generator functions more at infinite red
when we used Redux sagas and basically
allows you to suspend execution of a
function and go out back to the caller
several times you can yield yield yield
back to the caller several times it's
strange and yes
so that's generator functions generally
speaking I use async await for anything
that that means but there are some cases
okay so in mob x state tree if you use
that which is a state management library
then you may run into that as well for
of versus for in as mentioned previously
octal and binary literals big int new
number methods more class stuff mix-ins
typed arrays reg X new improvements Maps
and sets are cool so Maps would be we we
used all our object examples here
probably could have met maps instead but
objects are they have a nice clean
literal syntax so it damos better but
maps are helpful in certain cases or
week naps sets as well sets you can only
put one of a thing in two if you add it
again it won't come won't add anything
so those are helpful in some cases proxy
reflect objects so proxy object would be
wraps an object and acts as if it's that
object and can pass things through but
it can also intercept calls so if you
call the function on it then they would
say up no I'm gonna do something
different array from and of math methods
shared memory and Atomics because
they're starting to move toward
potentially a multi-threaded model right
now it's all like single core single
thread everything but they may
eventually want to go that way and if
they do that then they're gonna need
some way to share memory and do and like
lock memory and stuff like that yeah so
JavaScript isn't technically
multi-threaded it's it's still singles
right but but you're right like it it
hides all that away from you exactly
most of the stuff you're looking at here
you're not gonna use that as an
application developer it would be a
library author or something like that
that exposes a nicer API to whoever is
consuming your library but these are
additional tools in the tool belt I've
never actually used them so to be honest
I don't know I would assume in something
like that yeah I also did not top talked
about typescript except for when I
mentioned the compiler
I love typescript it's amazing it adds
types as well as additional other things
to JavaScript it is a big influential
part of JavaScript it is something you
should keep an eye on even if you don't
learn it so I did not talk about that
but it is important and part of the
story some more resources and I'll make
this these slides available and the
meetup group a whole bunch of stuff
one of my favorites is node green
because I do a lot of node development
and node green tells me what versions of
node have what features so I can see you
know does is there an array dot of in
node 9 or whatever and then that that
will just show me it's a big chart
there's an additional one for browsers
called compat table so
that is it that's my talk so thank you
all
[Applause]